you left out the mark hamill grunts good
actor as he is as soon as he does mad
it's like junker I mean this one this in
this performance I mean sometimes you
get certain people for their voices and
you want that type of way so obviously
they wanted a very evil sort of subtle
sounding Joker III it's it's very Mark
Hamill just like you know if you get
Steven bloomer or Johnny and Basha
sometimes you feel that soak it up the e
yeah you you want that evil but like you
know it's him well enough until your he
gets into a fight and then David Oh
Batman stop um so ya got it really is
where to think like it's done it's like
actually done no more left
no no more left but yeah so okay um the
big finale man uh to think the cabbage
salesman was behind it the whole time I
know and when he rigged the train to
crash to find the avatar secret power he
was secretly mr. glass yeah and and that
turns out that a Katara was dead the
whole time uh yeah that's when I told
him the ending was good and that uh you
know that one episode where they all got
sick house just the trees trouble and
this whole kingdom actually exists in
our world yeah that's right she is
modern world it just seems like it's
back in time because the people who are
running the earth Kingdom of Basia you
know Ba Sing se and everything are
controlling all the information so we
don't realize it's modern time but when
Qatar goes out to get medicine she know
he gets hit by a car and the Painted
Lady in the water that really threw
me for a loop - yeah yeah after Earth
okay let's that you talked about the
fucking um know that you have sort of
like okay so it's the sort of do us as
ba kina little bit uh you know cuz it's
like the turtle does something to them
but you don't know what and it's this a
deuce it did I say a douche did you just
say dude every Wes its machina juice I
you know we're gonna say the characters
names right I'm not gonna start now okay
with actual phrases I now you're
confusing let's write into the opposite
okay I'm pretty sure it's Dave's Alex
machina okay you're probably right on
that so if not they'll hunt us like dogs
so okay so you got he does the whole
thing with the energy and he's like he's
taking his energy away from him
something that the lion turtle whatever
that was
I gave Dan a special gift and what had
happened unbelievably impressive I get
two collars two lighting and the even
just like when they're doing the
firebending was you'll is doing the
firebending a glows blue I meet just
like everything goes shadow everything
goes blue and it all matches like just a
little pillar in the background like it
reflects off of there I mean just
wonderful detail on this um and so you
got this incredible scene you know he
takes away his uh his firebending and
first I was like okay I guess I sir was
hoping maybe it was something like you
could actually figure out sort of you
know they get super sent of the fans oh
no no it's a gala feel but the reason I
think about your opinion that's what
else there is
yeah I mean there is a split so I I
think it works though because I I think
they're playing that we've gotten to a
point in time where things have been so
thrown out of balance that things have
to come back to this balance that it
seemed like here's a creature that this
you know blind turtle whatever that was
thing I know you completely wrecks that
every time a cut to mine you would
the roar he did about the time give
another dog give him a one give him a
ride
so such a dick it seems like this looks
like an ancient creature of bajillion BC
you know I mean it just looks
unbelievably old it almost looks like it
came back to sort of help restore
balance by giving him this tool that was
needed because things have gotten so bad
and they were about to get a million
times worse and everything about this
show seems to be about balance that
things are thrown out of balance the yin
and the yang but now it's really going
to go to a point where it's it could
never come back dogs and cats living
together man that's a serie so it just
to play where it couldn't come back and
and this was the way of finally
intervening something where it could
come back um so and on top of that I
thought it was done so effectively well
I mean it's like something out of a it's
like something out of this really big
grand movie just this big epic and it
took its time this is all my
interpretation so what are we gonna are
so um I trap it and okay so where's my
mother
oh I'll tell you in this three-part
comic now available or cloning with the
promise the promise just one big cock
tease - getting a little closer three
you'll have to see we have the balls to
fake you out again are the last cock the
last ball bender uh oh yeah I mean that
from a show standpoint I do sir to go
really go wit Fagin where's my mother
hi let's go get tea it's like wait a
minute I wonder how much of this is I
keep reading and I've never been able to
get the full story how much this is a
Knick for I heard rumor that it was
supposed to be a four season show ends
up being three knowing what happened
with Korra that they only got greenlit
apparently for one season now I know
it's three and like having seen it I
won't say anything but like you can tell
it I know what does Nick
we not realize when they've got a really
good like product on their hands and
they just don't have faith in well I
mean like so many thing and I mean I
don't know if that's what happened here
but it seems to be this pattern with
them you know so maybe that was I mean
I'll go into that when we Emmy we should
do prayer like just a show some up and
the end too but um uh yeah just as a
show in general I mean there's always
stuff that's like you know a lot of
stuff comes back which is really
ingenious and really smart a it's like
oh cool how that all came back and tied
together you know as something's done
which is fun it's a show and it we
really the fact that we're expecting
that at all now just shows how high they
raise the bar um but to end a show on
where's my mother and even if we cut
there it's like who are they building up
to and even it's nothing it's like oh
well and the fact that it says where's
my mother and they just cut in having
tea and I'm just like wait a minute
what's the scene we skip yeah it's like
yeah Jen yo it was like watching Man of
Steel yeah we skate lands under he's a
grown man on about okay so so ninety yes
I that's the only thing else just her
like oh well that's odd um but no
everything else I felt really tiny I
took care I can't just the animation the
colors on this I mean just like the last
a shot of the clouds and all the various
colors worked out nice I love the way
everything seemed to come together I
love seeing Zuko as a fire Lord I love
seeing where me and Ty Lee went I love
seeing all the characters Abby it's so
happy it's one of those fucking happy
endings resore wish it will never end
just like what happened to like Return
of the King where you wish me would hop
yeah it was like this is the absolute
problem returning the king I kind of
wish this went on longer yeah so but
that that's what you want you want leave
him wanting more um yeah actually so
much it was her like half was the the
finishing climax and the other half was
the was the epilogue showing what
happened everybody which I'm fine with
um by 100 Kyra to say my friends you bow
to know why
um and the fight scenes again with with
the fire Lord and what aang wonderful I
mean just the way goes in the Avatar
State and just I love getting the air
and the fire and the spoiler alert yeah
I know God so no I I love the way it
ended I I felt was really wonderful and
it seemed like just that massive ending
you wanted and maybe you know like I
said my first Saudis are like oh well
what if something is something I could
figure out but maybe wouldn't be quite
as epic maybe because yet you got the
you got the ending where Katara freezes
Azula and then sir that's the
calculating one you know freeze and then
use a power to slowly bend through grab
the chain and tire down and stuff like
that's really clever that's the using
your brain one you know this one is the
big Jerry saviano's Sokka and Toph and
um Sookie - there was a lot of thinking
on your feet and using your brains in
that battle as well yeah so it's and now
we have the battle s+ piece or the big
you know the big cool effect and the big
the big rule breaker essentially hey
here's something we haven't told you
about but we got were throwing something
new at you that you didn't expect and
and couldn't see coming so I'm fine with
that because we had two other climaxes
where they did use their heads and they
did show all the things that they could
use to defeat them and that's what they
use so I was behind that I think hard
about cuz at first I was is somewhere
boat of I wasn't calling it a
straight-up deus ex machina but I was
like it's deus ex machina desk yeah um
and I've I came around pretty quickly
cuz I started thinking about the whole
show and I'm like okay think about a
beginning dad and the more and more I
thought about it the more I'm just like
no this makes total sense within the
world they presented the second you give
us a world where you can bend things
because people like well they came out
of no it's like being solved by magic
you're already living a world I'm
watching the show and they ready was and
they show how long it was around the I
got the idea of ajaita creatures and
magic Reacher's and stuff like that
how long a lot of these things and
people can last yeah it it worked really
well my my only criticism of it is this
the reason I think it seems like a deus
ex machina is because it was so thrown
at you so quickly if they threw that
creature in earlier possibly and I know
people are gonna come on like well
there's hints everywhere this is picture
of a turtle in the background and in
episode 15 or so it's like it's alright
check it out
the turtle is showing up in in places in
the background but oh that's cool yeah I
mean that's cool but I know it's not Val
yeah yeah it's not showing you know this
is it
that's an Easter Egg that's not you know
um but so the way and the way was thrown
at you so quickly it gives that
impression but I was like thinking about
how the story was progressing I was like
okay everything they did from the very
beginning you can bend the elements the
world is out of balance
there are spirit guides and spirit
animals in this entire spirit world you
basically set up this concept
particularly when Aang is involved that
it seems like nature is going out of its
way to help him that the issue is the
universe is out of balance and it seems
like considering the luck they have and
considering the communication he had
we've established the spirit world with
the giant panda monster and this and
that we've got the dragons but if you
establish that it looks like the
universe of nature itself is trying to
help him and therefore it's just a giant
metaphor people were just like well the
answer just showed up too it was like
how many times does that not happened in
your life every once a while you'll sit
down and be like I don't know what to do
and then poof what it's excellent you or
you get just good luck or something
fortuitous there's a lot of these
stories that sort of like you know
whatever Narnia or dune or you know the
shows that are these um stories where
it's like the prophecy and the chosen
one and the one said to lead us to bla
bla bla and I used to like them but now
I've gotten really out I think they're
just tired and boring and they sort of
take out the idea of choice um but what
I
found with something like this I thought
this did very well if that doesn't seem
like hey here's the one person that's
going to bring boughs and everything it
seems like no the universe has a way of
working its way it things will get to
have alignment but it'll come back
the story is Taoist ik it's the yin-yang
yeah so you know he's one of the
elements that really pushes it but it's
still just all coming around everything
seeme rarity helping a guinea that was
there and that's why when I was talking
about this split that happens in the
group way back when and you were just
like well don't you think cantar is kind
of wasting her time healing all these
people and isn't that a legitimate point
and you know I couldn't say too much
about it but this is what I meant of
like no because this is exactly the
point of the show which is for every
person who's like Zuko or Ozai or Azula
or even the good intention people who
were just like no kill you know Aang and
Katara represent the side that is like
no there has to be another way and
unlike some prophecy stories I thought
this was profoundly about choice ya know
and that's what I like it makes and I've
read a lot of criticisms from people who
are just like well I don't like it
because Aang basically the lesson it's
teaching children is that children
should just neglect the responsibilities
and their duties and clearly an had to
do something for the greater good and he
avoids it this whole time I was like
when show me at what point he said I'm
not going to do what's right for the
greater good the turtle island the lion
turtle island thing calls to him and he
had no point runs away from Ozai he just
says I have to sit and think about this
and he uses his resources he uses the
resources that is given to him and he
fine he finds a new way he at breaks he
he gets this way this peaceful way by
breaking a rule actually breaking the
decimal everyone says you kill all of
the adults in the room and this was
something I thought was very powerful
almost comically so about the Star Wars
trilogy the original one and it's
something that this one
is here which is why I think they do
have some similarities I whether it was
on purpose or not I don't know I think
this is great I have no problem with it
if it's kind of like Star Wars but all
of the adults in the room in both of
these sort of incarnations are the ones
are just like not Killa think of obi-wan
Yoda you know then the Emperor is
already one you know you have to in this
case all of his past lives kill him
Zuko kill him even Sakai things like
yeah you know you can you know and Aang
says no I'm not going to do it and all
these people are just like well the
greater good yes kill masc I'm just
gonna say this how many things in this
world have gone catastrophic Lee wrong
because of the greater good how people
did not question that maybe what we
think is the greater good may not be the
right way and far from being a bad
example for children this is the best
damn example I can think of because he
doesn't shirk his responsibilities he
did that at the beginning he throws
himself in ice he doesn't do that again
instead he sits there and he says you
know what I don't have to accept what
the adults are telling me not because
I'm being told to go to bed early or do
my homework but because fundamentally
I'm being told this is wrong all the
kids who end up being raised is racist
or taught to bully or you know had they
been taught in an early age to just
question that what a better world this
would be hmm
the nod Finn vo I guess are gonna help
why I mean you know just because the
world is telling you one thing doesn't
yeah I mean we're just we're we had two
great example this is like oh well if
you're not racist like the rest of us
then you'll go to hell I guess in the
bible's in well then I guess I'll go to
hell I mean that's basically what Aang
is doing he's like in my heart in my
soul this is wrong
now my question is I haven't seen Legend
of Korra but okay avatar dies three more
times what the hell's he gonna be
reincarnated ass what do you mean
well the airbenders are all gone um well
the cycle goes so the next one's gonna
be water yeah exactly but we dies three
more times he's gonna come around to
airbending again what the hell's gonna
happen then well
he's an airbender and Katara's gonna
shift hi listen Katara we got get some
other airbenders here see this is one
kill done defending because if I told
you were it's for the greater good
oh this is what kills me cuz if I told
you your answer that question these
clowns out here I guess I can't believe
you I'm not gonna say but it's already
sort of like a feud because it's like
you know if you die the Avatar state the
Avatar can never come back and it's like
well if he dies as like Legend of Korra
the next avatar like oh so I'll wait
steep answers that too you know I get
what I mean if he dies in the Avatar
state that's what they said he said you
know if you died the Avatar state though
and the avatar will never be
reincarnated he dies in the Avatar State
as ill ago show and he dies he comes
back we still fucking die yes I thought
he was healed by Katara wasn't he
nobody's like dead
a lightning ghost kid to do piccaboo and
she used her magic bring back to life
what ha but you see is on me half dead
yeah I mean so I have that in there if
if that wasn't I didn't think he was
really dead I thought Katara because
that's what the water does okay okay
so if you fall over dead now that'd be
awesome
but nice know if you - if you fall over
dead now besides taking over the side I
would at least attempt to revive you
because it's on camera now if that
happened and I had like a defibrillator
something and I'm like clear and you
wake up yeah you were dead technically
but you're still a little bit okay make
it like hell I have that plot device in
here if it never really comes into play
except for a little tuna that's really
what I thought I thought when they kill
it's like oh my god so this is like the
last one this is really the last balance
that we could possibly have to this and
that I help me back he'll come back you
know you can't edit on so
yes I'm that's Isaiah fie I mean it's it
because to me that was like the biggest
planet holy shit like when they said I'm
like wow like everything's just been a
Haupt big time for any liking if we're
nitpicking then why does Susan go to
save Roku and then just decide in the
middle of a change I don't get that
either there very few new things like
adipic about anyway yeah when I saw
again when we argue about this we argue
about a Nickelodeon show and we're
arguing about like the yin and yang like
Nickelodeon show living I don't care
Nickelodeon's never put out something
that's incredible and I'm going to safe
without more incredible things you are
you're doing legend Korra which I
haven't seen but I hear is awesome and
yes well you say here's a question yeah
I'm saying this show is raising the bar
it's raising Nickelodeon to a whole new
level and good for Nickelodeon another
thing cuz I've been talking about this
back and forth on my fan Facebook um a
number of people had an issue with the
fact that it's Zuko and Katara versus
Azula instead of just Zuko and Azula
what did you think
oh there's enough mono e mono I mean I
think it's you know so much of what Zuko
has done has been alone so I think the
idea of having somebody else by his side
and allowing her to come in especially
someone don't want nothing to do with
him and turn him aside said I will never
be anything it's another redemption
story yeah so I was okay with it I think
something could people were just like oh
now I did TV the two of them together
I'm gonna con say I'm not convinced that
either of them would have won if it was
just one on one if you look at the way
that battles going I mean there is
something metaphorical going like that
this whole thing kind of runs a metaphor
in the last episode and one of the
metaphorical things going on with those
three is when it's Zuko versus Azula
it's fire versus fire it just seems like
this could go oh yeah I was saying that
well though a battle fire versus water
technically catarrhalis well yeah and
that's the thing and when Azula by being
there Katara
makes herself a target but that allows
Azula to basically cheat as far as I
thought an Agni Kai was basically
just mano-a-mano one person on one
person yeah she drives she suddenly
involves somebody else and when the
second that happens
Zucco gets hit but that means the gloves
are off katar can do whatever the hell
she wants isn't that just a battle and
yeah you're right water defeats five
well and the other thing too that I
think is playing in so well is that you
have you know these people they always
say yeah you you show mercy you're weak
you're weak and these people at show
mercy Zuko has shown mercy and now he
has people to help him he has guitarra
to help him out
Azula has nobody she's banished
everybody nobody wants to help her it
practically looks like she banished the
city I have my guard sees you if I
didn't banish them all she's like Jack
lemons character in the grey race
banished banished so I mean so I think
that's a great testament to cuz again I
was talking about before words like as
much as it's like cool of the bad guy
goes out in a bad way when you really
get down to it so many times I say if
you just leave them alone and it's like
they usually are self-destructive and
they will sort of destroy themselves and
a lot of that is cuz they have nobody
men sure yeah they're the new there's
nobody to support her there was nobody
on her side cuz there is never any
kindness um exactly so so no I I
actually think that worked out very well
I thought that was very well handled uh
I will say one of the things is when I
what I first saw this I think I posed
that Facebook I'm like this whole thing
this whole climax plays out like Return
of the Jedi - all the damn Muppets oh
yeah is the best of all world
yeah no I really really is I'm just like
this really reminds me of like Return of
the Jedi if you removed the Ewoks and
that was like when so um yeah wonderful
ending I I love the way this all came to
a giant climax beautifully animated I
thought everything was fulfilling except
for the manga thing but that's you know
they're they're doing the thing you know
whatever my comic whatever oh she's in
the tea house oh let's go more tea oh
cool all right I'm just gonna cop to it
I have no
um so uh yeah I guess just final
thoughts on the show all together it is
a show such as never has been no never
will be again
I is it I thought it was amazing I could
go toe-to-toe with I mean it is anime
influence I said go toe-to-toe with any
anime um toe-to-toe with any cartoon
show in the u.s. one of the best cartoon
shows the United States has produced I
mean when I think of a great just batman
the animated series gargoyles this
actually what reminds me of is from
Nickelodeon's early days mysterious
Cities of Gold the way it had this sort
I think I was friend yeah I was a friend
French Japanese it yeah okay um yeah but
I mean they go okay Nickelodeon ran it
they didn't produce it but um yeah money
then we had this group of kids and it
was this epic adventure yeah this trip
on this song stuff forever it's like
Nikolai is not very associated with
comedy uh there which is fine but there
was a time where as very much you know
sort of comedy and service just mythical
wondrous thing you know then you weren't
it was sort of a grand pot of everything
um you know and I don't know of you cuz
I've seen maybe half your V Lanza I know
if it's been touched upon in depth but
what a great show for girls
dalia all of the female characters in
this show not only go toe-to-toe with
the boys but are just as compelling and
you don't even think about it yes to me
well-written is that just logon every
once awhile you get that episodes like
girls can't do this and it's are like oh
no I sit through things like brave which
I didn't get it just like in your face
and yeah it is so just hammering this
thing in and I think of other shows like
um I want to say maybe like Captain
Planet or know the the reboot of
ghostbusters they did a while back where
they got this group of
of hipster people in a wheelchair yeah
one guy wasn't it we all share one but
it was such a how do I describe it cuz I
have no problem if you want to get
different personalities races creeds
abilities together but it seems so
contrived it was the token you know
token and you look it's yeah it's with
just seemed like a bunch of tokens and
you look at this where you've got a
character like Toph a blind girl who
kicks ass and I think most importantly
her what you would call like a
disability or you know a disadvantage or
something being blind is her greatest
asset yeah you know and every character
has it every character is something a
lot of work it was in your week yeah
working with in something that the
universe is dealt you and turning it
into something really really power yeah
they train your weakness into your
strengths essential you know and they
run the full gamut I mean tops a tomboy
you've got Sookie she's a warrior who
also falls in love you've got Katara
who's the healer and the moral center
you've got Azula what a great villain
you've got Mei and um Ty Lee you know
those two alone just each have their
distinct personalities this is
incredible yeah I sir say it's like it
for me this is sort of like Game of
Thrones for kids in a sense it's like
you know like hey kids you want see what
we like about Game of Thrones but we
can't show you yet because you'll shit
your pants for a week get watch avatar I
mean you don't think kids should see
rats trying to crawl through some of
these chests just nailing heads up
spikes and stuff like there's more keep
really bridging that um so yeah for me
honestly this is my new favorite show
and it used to be Daria but no it's like
this this is in mad this is like this is
the all encompassing everything show it
has comedy it has adventure it has
suspense it has drama it has you know
great commentary has philosophy it has
wonderful animation has wonderful
characters as a wonderful story nothing
in it is not wonderful and it doesn't
betray its ethics no all the people are
just like I wanted aim to kill him at
the end I'm just like I don't think you
got it yeah
I am sorry I just don't think you got it
this is guy I watch it again and we'll
talk but died and this guy from someone
who you know I I said very honestly I
didn't know was gonna give me a job or
not but I said I'm all those people
where I don't always believe that
violence is never the answer and even at
some points or Vectra it's like violence
is never the answer then the next
episode Easter I like you know I only
use violence in self-defense it's like
wow how lonely you know it's like that
shows you know it can be done this is
one thing I want Luke to just take down
Vader and the Emperor with what I got
like don't act up like that doesn't work
that way I don't think you're
understanding what's yeah no I mean I
agree you sort of mishit you're enjoying
the action missing everything else if
that's the case um I I thought was so
well-balanced I thought talk about a
show and a world that completely took
advantage of what it had to not just the
nth degree but just beyond what it could
do and what people probably perceived it
and I I'm just a man you know and I
purposely stayed away from commentary
and anyone talking about so I could be
surprised see what happens now I want
know all I can about like how this show
was made how the creators of this made
this happen because this does not happen
you know not them like an aficionado
while curtain curtain kids films or
kisum's of like what the past eight
years something like that whatever
osho's of this quality yeah I mean it's
just even Batman the Animated Series
it's one it's a it's not a flaw because
the creators made it that way it's a
flaw in the nature of what Batman is
that you can't have sort of one long
story arc yeah it doesn't work with them
and it has to be episodic closest in
that category would probably be the
x-men cartoon the first season yeah
which even then down
that's hokey and it has his problems and
stuff hey I wanted images no this was
just laces a rarity in the Asian to I
mean and the fact that it got the fact I
caught on so much I mean that for lack
of a better term that really gives me
hope
folks just and I'm Nadia play sound like
Oh humanities let us down I'm not there
at all you were remotely but it does
give me so much hope for not just adults
but the kids watching this that kids
watch this they enjoy they want to see
more are you listening Nickelodeon are
you hearing this lobby
don't let your core I mean so it's a
weekend we yeah but it took forever just
to get that off the ground and even
though it's like well we'll give you
ones oh I guess we're getting our own
game well by I thought it dicking around
with this I have no idea how long this
show took to make my guess would be this
took a very long time to put no I'm not
talking about that I just mean from
everything I've read you know it's just
like oh well we'll give you one season
like I guess we'll give you more than
that I'm like why wouldn't you
greenlight three or four seasons of a
sequel series to avatar on faith alone
well we've seen the tribe do meio
Pirates of the Caribbean another stuff
but I tend to agree it's like yeah very
least you're either team behind Pirates
was as good as this no no but that's
what I'm talking about that no they're
just looking from a marketing standpoint
sure though by I agree going in is how
you should have especially knowing how
the last would days you have an idea a
couple seasons at least um you willing
you would think so no I'm it's really
it's raise the bar for me in terms of
like just what you see in terms of
animation and kids shows it just shows
in general honestly uh this is it is so
taken me back I think I mentioned this
early on but I'm just saying again it
really took me back to that excitement
and that joy that I used to really feel
as a kid again when I just being so
invested but also having so much fun
that's why I said mysterious Cities of
Gold because that was the one that I
always would come home from school like
when I was in the second grade or
something and tried to throw on because
I just wanted to know what was going on
or what was happening and and I think so
much of our entertainment now is I don't
want to say too adult because I think
this is very adult but I think there is
sort of that element of fun that we're
purposely trying to leave out because
either show wants to be taken seriously
or may we're too cynical and we don't
want to I think San Pedro
goofy or silly but this shows found such
a perfect balance it just shows it can
be done it can be done very well and it
should be done more often um so I'll
just blow away by this show it's to me a
good at history show to me a good kid
show should give you a sense of ethics
that is very adult yeah and I mean
that's the thing I think what why talk
down about the most important essential
elements which is why I thought angin
that's what that happens between Aang
and Katara was so key is because that is
what an adult should really do we get
stuck in this violent mindset of just
like now we can kill him
oh we can fight fire with fire and it
just keeps perpetuating itself we're
very good yeah and people just look well
that's the adult thing to do them like
no it's not it's a vengeful thing that's
the vengeful petty thing to do that
that's the entire wish thing honestly I
know even though I don't like violence
you know I say violence is the route
when you can't find anything else you
know when you're not smart enough to
find anything else may there is no other
solution but it still comes down to you
were not smart enough to find anything
else and we do and and I'm not like you
lately but you know I've resort to
violence or something like that you know
anyway not twice um but no it's one of
those things where it's like you know I
would acknowledge I was not strong
enough or smart enough to find the right
solution we do have failings in the show
shows it's okay to have aliens and you
can come back from them even a couple
failings like in the case of Zuko and
Aang for that and if somebody tells a
twelve-year-old that you have to kill
somebody maybe you don't have to listen
to yeah good lesson kids good lesson if
your past life sorry to kill somebody
maybe there's another way so I mean
that's the brilliance of Lucas of the
writers of this show is religion when
you look at the teachings of all the
major religious leaders it's really
really hard that's what makes it really
adult and it's like no it's so simple
nope nothing you
lived enough life maybe look at the
teachings of Jesus of Buddha you know of
Allah Muhammad and you can go on and on
but you know most of them it's insanely
difficult to live a life completely
unselfish without resorting to violence
you know if it was easy why would they
be teaching it yeah and sorry he's like
oh no egg found the easy way out I was
like no I didn't the easy way I would
have been just freaking kill him yeah
not bad and I'm doing game over I mean
it's so much easier to you just need to
create and hold on the create event how
Fire Nation I think would just would
have looked at him it was like oh well
here's a COO somebody just took over and
you know I think by sparing him you know
and letting him live I think it sets a
better example and by planting the seeds
with dance party oh comes vozack all
comes full circle that the dance party
but you know what Qatar was doing it
it's a way better example so we more
adult than I think some people give this
yeah credit for uhm so yeah pretty much
um now we got the shovel on movie to
look over to you are I so excited you
are in for a treat so that I'll tell you
right now I shot so the next review is
going to be an editorial after that I
shot a review in a calm Bravo that's
going to be next because that was a big
review a show with a lot producer so bad
that's coming up then another editorial
and then yeah I'll go right into lesser
bandwidth that um and I can't wait I've
seen it already it's Oh God
aside from that uh a lot of people have
been asked me to do logic where am I
gonna do Legend of Korra belie yes you
are
yeah why not I there's no reason not to
if it's the same people I did this I'm
interested in anything these actually
it'll be nice because after the first
season if you catch up in time we can
watch it together and I don't have to
hear shit about like you just came with
away yeah well no that's where the fun
to was watching this was not looking at
the comments not knowing anything about
it staying away from anything I knew
about it because then I could come at it
not being influenced by anybody
anyway no you forget things one day
later anyway well yeah that's true too
it doesn't really matter so um yeah so
that's coming up uh avatar my new
favorite show still a crappy movie with
blue cats but my new favorite show still
one of my favorite shows so awesome take
care guys spent a lot of fun